hi
today i'm going to uh
go through in depth about kokodaki
i've recently been asked about coke and
aggie and over the years
i've been asked
pretty much the same question
people like koginagi but
it's a very
involved
part of aikido
i think that um
personally until you get to at least
third fourth down
the the uh aikido is not really you know
equipped to take on multiple attackers
and the reason is uh
panic even a black belt will panic
and this takes years and years to
overcome and realize that you know
you're in the now
you're surrounded by
aggressive people
and you've got to handle yourself
and hopefully come out of it in one
piece
so i'm going to show you um seven pieces
of paper
now forgive the writing but i hope you
can decipher it
and each stage
is how i see
kokinagi being formed
years gone by we had uh
lots and lots of people in our clubs and
coquinagi wasn't a problem because you
could always find uh
let's say eight people like the the
the
amount of people i've chosen to
for this uh
program is is eight attackers
you're the ninth one
so
with the class now being much smaller it
appears to be worldwide
you can do it on
two three people you're training
and i suggest that you systematically
start with a um very slow
and work through a process
a systematic process that you can
understand
you know make it a formula that you
finally work through and see how it
works
and what will happen is even in the dojo
with people that you know
and trains all the time and they're not
really a threat apart from your
morals and your ego being
bruised
once they start getting faster and
coming at you a lot harder
you'll notice how what i mean about
panic and then it just becomes a
free-fall and very scrappy and untidy
so the common one i
recommend you start with is where they
come and they they grab
the two shoulders you know you you offer
the two shoulders
uh
leo cutter
dory
two hands grab two shoulders
and you tell everybody to do the same
as time goes on uh you can vary this
what they do
when they strike punch grab
you know
and they'll be coming from your all
angles
okay
so even though i'm saying it's an
advanced
in my opinion that is it's an advanced
uh
form of techniques
we can start them at any level and it's
fun at any level and i encourage you to
do it
so
what i do i'll hold each
one up and it's very rough so please
forgive me if if you think that i should
be a better artist
i should hold each one up
and
hopefully
you can either freeze the screen read it
and see what it says
okay so that's the first one
i'll just read it
you're you're the red dot by the way
so
number one
this person comes to you so they're the
first one to attack
you throw them you turn you throw them
to number two
hopefully you use them like a bowling
pit ball and it knocks the skittle down
it knocks them down or it it gives you
time
to um
be ready for the others
okay so
they come at one
you throw to two
and three
is the next
person to two
and
you can either throw them at two or
three depending on what you sense is the
threat
this is going back just a little by
saying
you know you're in the middle
they're all there
whoever decides to attack you first
may not always be the closest person to
you but whoever attacks you first
is the one that you take so these
uh examples
are exactly what they say
so after connecting
with three
i'm just going back
explain this one
you've thrown number one into two
you then you'll see the two-way hours
you then
yourself go to number three
okay you must go to number three do not
stand in the middle
or else you'll be defeated
once you go to number three
you are then
on the outside of the circle
okay
so
i'm hoping my words will explain
everything to you
in the cards
you will go to number three and possibly
as
um
on the other side you've already from
one you've knocked over two or you've
given them something to think about
they're on the floor trying to gather
themself or get out of the way
and three throw into number four because
you're on the outside they're the
closest one to you
so now you're here on the outer part
of the circle
so even though they're wanting to attack
you
you have as much advantage as any of
them because you're on the outer circle
you may not about to run away at this
point even though you're out of the
threat
they might all start now deciding to
descend on you
so you have to become
a weaver where you weave in and out and
you go
from point four
again these are only examples you go
to point five
you must go from four to five very fast
because they're all going to be coming
at you at 0.4
but because you swiftly move to 0.5 you
then choose
like with number four
you and number three
you start choosing them you could think
that um
you be you've become the attack all of a
sudden but the point is
[Music]
number one attacked you in the first
place so it's already been set in motion
so you then need to start weaving in and
out
but keeping always to the outer circle
starts getting a little bit
hectic now a little bit busier
where from five
the
ones that you've already thrown are nice
and busy trying to sort themselves out
and hopefully if you've done a good job
they're not going to be able to come at
you
like the other four
who are all standing still
they're starting to rush at you
you're on the outside but by then you've
gained speed in your movement and you're
you're swerving in and out so as they
come to you
at point five let's say the the closest
arrow for argument's sake
let me just put a six on there
so
at
from five
they all come at you you actually charge
as fast as you can and go to six and
throw them into
seven or eight
or whoever's the biggest threat perhaps
one of the others that you threw earlier
has regained their self and they're
coming back at you
so i'm hoping that that's explained
everything to you this goes into really
the finalization
where
they've all
been thrown
because this is
you must do all this at very high speed
and that's why again the level of
black belts i said about third or fourth
down really i put fourth down on here
okay so you you're there you can run
away
to safety or get yourself out of
problems they're all in the heap
or
that's how you hopefully you've ever
neutralized them all so they have no
threat to you
but get out of the way
okay
so you can always freeze um
pause the screen and
read what it says
and if it makes no sense to you then
please come back to me you know there's
there's uh
that you can ask on on the youtube site
if you have my email you can email me
if you wish to join my patreon site then
we can do a one-to-one
meeting on zoom and we can go through in
great greater depth
but
you have to not stand in the middle
i remember saying many years ago goes
oshioda
who they said was um or
he could have been as good as osensi or
he's very close to so
people put him up there as one of the
absolute ultimate best
if you watch him doing coke and aggie
you'll notice the way he quickly he's
very small man
but he weaves his way in and out in and
out he's never he doesn't stand there
and let them come to him
the biggest problem i see wherever i
teach doesn't matter what country in the
world
i get the students to
make a circle around the person
i then clap my hands and tell say you
know
go
they either all do but there's always
normally one who will be faster than the
others the person in the middle has to
turn looking 360
and and to stop being
alive you know for some reason usually
your hands are up not this high but
they're up um about your
chest level
and you're so already waiting for them
but what i find is they're so busy
waiting for the attack book is to come
to them they don't realize they're stuck
in the middle
they may not even move a meter out of
that spot but if you do that and you've
got eight attackers
even five four attackers if they're a
young fast
athletic uh students
they're going to wear you out and you're
going to be breathless in a very few
minutes
and because you're in that position it's
a bit like a boxer being boxed in the
head in the end they don't know where
they are so they just keep getting hit
and hit until they're knocked out
this is the same scenario that you will
find if you don't get out the middle
you must go in the middle until you've
had the first one and then you mustn't
have what happens is
the first one comes you turn you throw
them and there's a big sort of a lapse
in your brain and you sort of like and
you sort of reset yourself but you're
still stuck in the middle
what you have to do and this is what
takes years of training
the first person comes you turn you
throw them
and then you're off this throw should
mean that you're like the ball rolling
you should then go
[Music]
and then either go after the next person
in the line because you're going to them
and work your way around and as the one
of the
papers show you go anti-clockwise you
can go clockwise there's no problem it
just depends you know whatever way you
turn if you turn clockwise then keep
going clockwise you can turn clockwise
then turn anti-clockwise but the more
turning you do and the more confusing of
yourself you do
then you're not gonna
one day design a program that your body
memory will know
it's better to have confidence and know
your body memory
and to perform this this act okay so
good luck please try if you've only got
one person in your club at the time
being then just practice what i say and
and you know
throw the first person
go to that place
and imagine that the other person there
ask them to attack again and try to set
up a stage stager
choreographed system
you do really need a minimum of three to
uh
to get any sense out of it
it's a wonderful uh
it's good for cardiovascular it's very
good to put you under pressure
the the greater you
numbers you get the more you will panic
the more you will
if it's in a real situation i've been in
a real situation and your adrenaline
goes up and that also can confuse you
you just being sort of wired up
ready to almost be the fighter you know
reversing roles you know you're going to
try and protect yourself and that's when
the training has to come in so that your
body memory takes over your adrenaline
your panic all these things
and you will once you start um you would
do it but in a real situation your power
will be much greater
and it can be quite devastating on the
people receiving
uh
your power
okay thank you for listening any
questions always ask
thank you for your time